mais la halle aux messieurs bonsoir
c'est la troisième participation de
mathieu deroy cette émission c'est bien
ça c'est toujours aussi calme ici mais
je t'assure vous avais promis vous
enlèverez votre moustache si vous gagnez
un oui je vois je crois qu'elle ne
risque pas grand chose comme ici les
deux fois on a une chance encore
d'indépendants un homme bien et madame
domestiques ne la connaissons pas
puisqu'elle n'était pas aux côtés de
masquer la fois dernière madame
d'investir rapidement un petit
curriculum vitae
je vous laisse moi je suis marié j'ai
deux enfants et je fais des études de
dessin de mode départ sur les stimulus
que j'aime votre émission et que je la
suis le plus souvent possible très bien
et que votre france peut-être les
chiffres peut-être les chiffres alors
vous allez peut-être l'occasion d'en
profiter tout fitz pile ou face face
c'est parce c'est à vous pour le côté
1re 2e 1re 2e
1re 3e
10 6 6 8 9
[Musique]
je
e
non
[Musique]
ouf
voilà je suis content que ça commence
bien pour vous le méritez le compte est
bon
8 et 6 13
qu'est ce que vous
expliquez vous tombez 6,13 à dallas
bah oui j'en fais avec treize fois du
sang neuf
madame monsieur
renard tout va bien pour vous
non mais je veux dire en général ce que
vous êtes content d'être avec nous dans
lord effectivement tout à fait content
fait beaucoup rire
j'avais comme il est beaucoup de choses
mais c'est tous les coupés les cheveux
même bac d'ailleurs le score est de 6 à
rien en faveur de monsieur de roi et
c'est un tout les consonnes et consonnes
[Musique]
consonnes m
consonne
w
wyeth
wye l eau
[Musique]
consonne c'est
c'est normal ou plus peut pas vous
demander
pardon au début je croyais alors voyait
bien à ça me suffisait
il
[Musique]
shi
je reviens d'être 5 lot de métier le
mieux à mon
âme on
aime trop
incident naval charmant chanteur
d'ailleurs bien je voulais d'abord vous
lire un petit message de monsieur g en
garde savez le charmant candidats qu'ils
russie va voir une épique tout nous
couvre de fleurs et qui dit ceci tous
mes voeux de réussite à mon collègue
monture montreuillois monsieur derouin
j'espère que le profit la loi car s'il
m'a battu il fallait qu'il soit costaud
bien alors je vous présente monsieur
maintenant c'est le courrier des
lecteurs c'est peu et vecteur j'ai
d'autres lettres ça sera pour moi une
fois monsieur rouzier monsieur rouzier
vous venez d'ouvrir parisé pourriez vous
faites quoi dans la vie mais je suis
ingénieur en éco cités et plus
précisément vous fait quoi des plates
formes de forage pour les recherches
pétrole inchangée pétrole c'est un
j'espère que vous allez nous porter
chance j'espère sans ça quand vous ne
ferait pas ou quand vous faites là bas
je fais du sport et puis je joue au
scrabble aussi
enfin vous serez quoi merci
madame de métier puis les voyelles et
consonnes
et voyelles
console
voyage
conseille t consonnes
consonnes
[Musique]
marre de rester cinq lettres droit au
mieux les tiens tns
pour y en avait six y avait senti très
minable
11 à 5 ce droit les
1re
2e 3e 4e première deuxième
75 50 5 3 1 et 5
[Musique]
je
m
[Musique]
non monsieur leroi
780 196 mort de mme astié
797 alors cette nationale
5.5 10
75 de 750
50 - troyen 46
[Musique]
rien fait combien donner moult détails
troyen 450 - 4 46 fille c'est le chant
50,46 787
j'étais plus près mais enfin je ne vais
pas le compte je m'en excuse de
4,4 points pour monsieur droit 15 à
saint paul des sièges aux voyelles et
consonnes
et voyelles
et consonnes
console fait consommer
voyait
[Musique]
je
j
[Musique]
mais l'être s'il est là ce droit n'est
pas mieux des pères
y avait sept il y avait poivre au
pluriel 1
6 point pour madame de mercier
11ac monsieur hansson des consonnes
des consonnes
s consonnes et voyelles
voyelles
brienne
consonnes
[Musique]
qui
ces droits
4 madame de m pas mieux
viser
haut j'avais un petit peu mieux avec
vide au pluriel enfin la pression qui a
même mieux que ça quatre points pour
mener ses droits de 19 à 11 les chiffres
de nouveau avec madame honesty 1re 2e 3e
4e 2e première
725 4 et 8
[Musique]
et 2 sans 3
d'accord bien
voilà
[Musique]
certes rotatif qui revient souvent mais
qu'on trouve facilement
[Musique]
et
l'air désolé de monsieur leroy n'ont pas
eu les
moyens de rester le compte est bon au
nom
sept mois 4 3 où logent
plus en 103
mardi les candidats six points faux
malade le vessier qui se rapprochent 19
à 17 monsieur droit consonnes h
consonnes c'est en somme elle consonnes
m
voyelles et noyelles et
voyelles y
wyon à
[Musique]
je
monsieur roy cinq lettres 50 ans de
métier mach
mâché attend ça oui à mailhac doit y
avoir là match doit y avoir la salade
j'imagine mais sûrement pas ce que vous
dites macha wii n'ont pas le droit de
conduire je vous le rappelle si vous
n'avez pas la salle 1 la salle adam
levine est exactement à choyer je remets
y avait une de mieux il y avait malice
une fenêtre aussi malicieuse ou max pour
trouver ça nous avons six points devant
chris un point pour monsieur
de roy 24 à 17 madame de mes citoyens
et consonnes et voyelles
console des voyages
et au singe et consonnes h console
[Musique]
je
oui
[Musique]
chn
de los ché sinclair droit si la tipp et
de digues
[Musique]
le jeu qu'on trouve en revenant bien au
top
30 à 17 messieurs droit 1er
2e 3e et 2e 4e 2e
6 9 de 10 7 5
[Musique]
j
donc monsieur d'euros
184 24
6 x 10 60
il faut 10 60 du coût deux fois 5 10
je pense en 10 x 66 ans
ne fait 7 16
600 - 16 580 kg le résultat non c'est
pourtant ce n'était pas très difficile
si x 9
plus si sage
59 je multiplie par 10 590 - ces
quatre points pour monsieur de roide 34
17 malades de mestiaen moyenne
consomme m voyage aux consoles mais
royal
console j'ai consoles
et console t
[Musique]
il
oui
[Musique]
on investit 5 lettres et droit
si le train oui une trombe le 30 2
trombes d'eau vous
et oui
nous y aller jusqu'à 7 et vous aviez un
ombrage à
[Musique]
monsieur deux roues qui finit en flèche
car apte à 10 investis promet pas mal
mais vous savez que encore une fois ce
n'est pas perdu leur ont eu des
remontées beaucoup puisque de chacune
des recettes vous entraîner d'ici la
prochaine fois oui être en pleine forme
ces droits a une grande habitude de jeu
maintenant est toujours aussi calme
apparent l'intérieur c'est quand même
mon intérieur c'est pas très calme
patrick roy s'est pas l'impression de
vous donner
voilà eh bien nous nous retrouvons avec
bien entendu les candidats la prochaine
fois avec
dany qui n'est pas très sage dans son
coin l'heure actuelle d'ailleurs elle
fume ce qui est interdit sur ce plateau
non mais je rigole partition
bien voilà écoutez je me mettais pour
les la voix je vous souhaite à tous une
très bonne soirée devant soi
[Musique]